over the best part of the past decade i
have studied the earth's atmosphere in
my masters and phd and i've also read
extensively on
the subject this is actually just a
small sample in this video i am going to
talk about the five books
i think you should read to better
understand climate change i'm going to
structure this video around
questions so start off by posing a
question that you may have about climate
change and then recommending a book that
will answer that
question while climate change is
fundamentally a scientific problem
it is also a political and economic and
sociological one because
climate change affects every aspect of
our society
and so some of these books are as well
as talking about the science also going
to address some of
those questions also before we start if
you like the look of any of these books
and fancy getting yourself a copy then
you'll find links in the description
which will take you to your local
amazon page for the books i would
encourage you wherever you can to
support local independent bookshops
because
they make the world a better place but
if you can't for whatever reason then if
you do use those links they're affiliate
links so i get a small cut of any sales
that get made
so it helps the channel okay so the
first question about climate change and
the one that i probably get asked the
most by my friends
is just how bad is it really and
somewhat tellingly i'm going to
recommend a book that answers this
question called
the uninhabitable earth by david wallace
wells
so this book is split into two major
sections the first of which basically
details in small chapters
what we think is going to happen over
the next century or so with climate
change and that's looking at
for example fires wildfires uh drought
uh war all these different aspects of
society that we expect are going to be
affected by climate change in the next
century and the short answer to the
question
is really not good this is definitely
not a book that you should read before
going to bed
i could personally only manage about a
chapter or two at a time at the first
section before uh
i kind of just needed to put it down and
go for a walk
the first half of this may well be one
of the most depressing books i've ever
read
it's pretty unflinching in how it
describes what's going to happen over
the next century
the second half of the book examines the
problem at hand so
what the current situation is with
climate change what we're doing
about it and why it's not currently
enough so it does give a very good broad
overview of the whole subject it's also
for the record absolutely beautifully
written the first half
is so chilling but it's also
wonderfully written if you're going to
read one book on climate change i'd
probably recommend this one above the
others in this video
second question how do we know that
climate change is actually
happening of course if you want the
in-depth answer to this question then
you should read the ipcc
reports that are available online for
anyone to read and the summary for
policymakers is
very easy to understand it has to be
it's meant for politicians however for a
slightly
friendlier introduction to the subject i
recommend the discovery of global
warming by spencer
r weird this is a pretty slim read and
i'll be honest i don't think it's the
most engaging text in the world
however i think there's a lot to be said
for a chronology there's a lot to be
said for being introduced to a subject
from
the beginning this book starts at the
beginning it starts with the pioneers in
the 19th century
like eunice foote and robert tyndall
saying that we
think this thing may be happening and
then going right the way up to the
present day so past new data coming in
past computer models being introduced
past
the rigor of a proof that was required
for such a momentous claim as
global warming it's worth noting that
whit is also a physicist and so
writes with a kind of detachment he
isn't in the middle of the thick of the
fight again so it's kind of an
i'm not going to say impartial view but
certainly allows for a lot of skepticism
because
fundamentally science is based on
skepticism extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
and this book kind of
kind of tells the story of that next why
do so many people
still think climate change isn't real or
i guess alternatively
why has so little been done to answer
that question i'm going to recommend a
book that is
phenomenal and also awful
and that's merchants of doubt by naomi
oreskis and eric m
conway i say that this book is fantastic
because it is one of the best books i've
ever read
it is a non-fiction account that is
meticulously
researched is beautifully presented is
as long as it needs to be
every page is is where it needs to be
there's no
fat on the bone yet it still tells an
incredibly compelling story and that
story
is the reason why it's also awful
because this book details what may well
be
come to be regarded as the worst crime
in the history of humanity
this has been through the wars when did
i do this
oh i'm a terrible book custodian the
book identifies a common playbook used
by some american scientists in the
20th century to cast doubt on topics
like
acid rain the dangers of smoking climate
change ozone depletion
and they're the same strategies used
time and time again and in some cases
the same scientists used time and time
again despite not being an expert in
any of those fields the book details who
did this
why they did it and why it's still a
problem i think it's a
really powerful message that everybody
should read
about misinformation absolutely
essential read it's a five star book
i am actually going to include a quick
bonus recommendation here and that's
don't even think about it by george
marshall i'm not going to say that this
is a book everybody
should read but i think it's a good one
if you regularly find yourself talking
to people who just
for whatever reason are head in the sand
on climate change they just don't want
to listen to reason
on the subject the book basically breaks
down why we suck at thinking about
climate change but also why we suck at
talking
about climate change and it offers some
really quite practical advice actually
on how to
better communicate the science and the
dangers
of you know what could be a really
disastrous century so if that's you if
you find yourself talking to family
members or colleagues or whatever about
climate change and they
just don't want to listen then maybe
that's a good one to read
but ultimate question what is being done
about climate change and
why isn't it enough i recognize this is
probably quite a divisive book to
recommend but i think the best answer to
that question
is found in this changes everything by
naomi klein
fundamentally this book is about systems
it's naomi klein looking at what systems
have landed us
in well hot water and are they capable
of getting us
out of it and she argues pretty
convincingly that no
they're definitely not the two systems
that she specifically looks at are
basically fossil fuels
and how we run the global economy you
know kind of new liberal economics it is
a book about
economics sociology and politics and as
such
i mean it's quite thick because this is
quite a this is quite a big topic
this is definitely a very left-wing book
and i'm sure by me saying that i've
immediately turned off a lot of people
on it but i would encourage people to
give it a read because
much as i don't agree with everything
she says in this book
and it's very very broad to the point of
being
frustrating view at the problem it's
difficult to disagree with her
fundamental argument
that really the systems that we have
been using
to this point to try and get us out of
this problem are the exact systems that
got us into this mess in the first place
and they're not going to get us out of
it it has been divisive
it is beautifully written i think it's a
five-star book
and at the end of it she actually draws
everything to quite a touching personal
conclusion
so it's kind of got a bit of everything
i i think you should read it
and then lastly the other question that
i got asked most frequently by friends
and family
what can we do about climate change to
answer this i'm going to recommend a
book
unlike anything else i've talked about
in this video
it's called drawdown edited by paul
hawkin
this book is different from all of the
other ones in this video because it's
not a
typical work of non-fiction it's a
coffee table book really it's large
format it's the kind of thing you just
have out in your house
but i think this is brilliant the book
is broken down into double page
spreads each spread details a particular
strategy a particular thing that we can
do either as individuals
or on a larger scale as societies they
range from putting
solar panels on your roof to using led
lighting to
using bio plastics and the crucial thing
is that for each strategy you're
presented with
three numbers the reduction in co2
emissions by 2050
if you were to introduce the strategy
the cost of introducing the strategy by
2050
and the amount of money you would save
by doing so
because here's the thing if you don't do
anything about climate change it's going
to cost
a lot of money i don't want to tell you
the wrong thing i'll put a figure up on
the screen from uninhabitable earth but
yeah it's a lot so what this book is
really powerfully arguing is that
here are so many strategies that you can
take
that will save you money in the long run
yes this is what they will cost
up front but look at how much money
you're going to save overall so
for example if you introduce smart glass
into buildings so
you know responding to what the
weather's doing a bit like those um
photoreactive
sunglasses then you would save some two
gigatons of co2 being emitted by 2050
and it would cost you about 75 billion
dollars
but it would also save you in the long
run 325 billion
something that i try and stress wherever
i can is that we have the technology
to fix climate change we have cheap
renewables we have
a full book full of the things that we
can do
it's just a question of finding the
willpower to do it and
most frequently that means political
willpower i think this book is important
because it details
the policies that you should be voting
for these are the policies that your
government
should be pursuing yes it is a glossy
coffee table book but it contains
incredible information that can make a
real
difference so i think every school
library should have a copy of this every
ceo
should read this you should send this to
your local
government representative because the
solutions are in here
this is this is what we need to do we
just need to do it so that rounds off my
list of books i think you should read
about
climate change uninhabitable earth the
discovery of global warming
merchants of doubt this changes
everything and drawdown
this is of course however a huge subject
and there are plenty of books that i
still haven't read on the subject
so if i've missed your favorite then let
me know down there in the comments i'm
always on the lookout to learn more as i
said at the beginning if you do fancy
getting any of those books there are
links
down there and if you do choose to get
something from those links then it does
help out this channel a lot thank you so
much for watching the video
i really hope that you picked up some
reading recommendations from this
this is the most important subject that
we will face in our lifetimes
and the better informed we are the
better able we will be as
a civilization to deal with it so i hope
that you've taken something away and
that you've learned something
if you enjoyed the video do please pop
it a like share it with your friends who
might be interested
and happy reading i'll see in the next
one